okay yeah um from rack to riches I know
we are in the llm track here in Piata
Global but still I am not going to
assume that everyone knows what rag is
so I'm going to um Define this real
quick and give us like a small
introduction for everyone who's not
familiar with the technique so sorry pH
you need share screen if you haven't
shared screen yet
oh yes that would
be um a good
idea okay
so now this makes sense like I was
saying we are doing all these things
here on the left these are the projects
we contribute to and uh employee
maintainance um let's go further um yeah
so Rec um we all know like all if you
are in this track you probably know what
an llm is and one of the limitations
that llm have is that they are trained
on vast but fixed data sets so meaning
they don't have access to upto-date
knowledge so just this morning I went
over to CH GPT and asked it hey what is
ragna so um this is the framework that
we have built and released like roughly
a month ago and we're going to talk
about in this uh in my talk here and
chat GPT correctly answers like hey I
was trained up to with knowledge up to
date like up to January 2022 I have no
idea what ragna is and it speculate
speculates and gives you tips how to get
this information but it's not able to
help you and so if you want to ask llms
questions about um fresh data you
basically have like two ways of doing so
so the first way is you can actually
find you your model so if you get hands
on the base model for cat GPT for
example gp4 you can take your data set
to it and can find un it but this is
kind of a lengthy uh Endeavor and it's
it could also be costly depending on um
how much finding you want to want to do
so this is not um like the the preferred
way um if you just want to ask questions
about documents or inter interrogate a
document so the preferred way to doing
that is basically adding the data that
you want to ask about um into the actual
prompt so if you instead of just asking
like hey um what is ragna you could ask
like here look at these documents that
I've passed for you and then answer me
the question what is ragna and just to
uh like uh give
an analogy for these two if it's um
maybe a little easier to understand like
the the case one fine tuning the model
would be building up long-term memory
for the llm so it can always access it
and like the second would be um to
basically give or present some
information to someone right now and
then ask him a question and apart from
the cost and um all that comes with it
like the the point one also has the
problem that you know with yourself like
if you have memories that are far uh
into the past
it's very easy
to um hallucinate this is the term that
is used for for llms and like that
happens to to us humans as well we just
our brain just fills up the information
and just uh tries to make up information
so um we can answer
questions um
the other use case the analogy there
would be someone tells you do know
someone tells you this and um um ask you
a question right after afterwards which
be would be like shortterm memory and
this is um a lot easier for us humans to
answer and for llms as well the problem
is um that this part two has is llms
have uh a fixed context size and this
context size is basically uh a measure
of how much data the llm can ingest in
uh in the single prompt so if you have
like a vast number of documents and you
want to ask questions about it you can't
just send all documents um all the
documents to to the llm and ask
questions about it and even if you have
an LM that has like a massive um context
size for example if you're familiar with
enthropy claw they claim up to two
200,000 tokens which is a few books uh
worth of um of text even if that is the
case you're still making it very hard
for the uh for the llm to answer your
question so imagine like someone reads
you three books and then asks you a
single question afterwards um it's
really hard to to figure out what is
actually the relevant information here
and so to overcome this this specific uh
problem of this case to um this is what
rag is doing so rag is the um short form
for retrieval augmented generation and
basically what it basically what is
happening is we have like a two two
stage
process um instead of just asking the
question and giving it the document we
start off by taking our documents
tokenize them um and put them in a into
a vector database so basically what
happens is we take our documents chunk
them up maybe in paragraphs maybe in
Pages maybe by the number of tokens
whatever scheme you have and um embed
them into uh into a vector which means
we now have um a vector numerical Vector
with like let's call it a few hundred
until a few few thousand uh dimensions
and put it into a vector database so
this is basically the first step that is
happen that is statically happening and
then if you ask a prompt instead of
taking everything from this document we
go with our query our prompt to our
Vector database and say hey this is my
prompt please also embed this and look
for chunks of documents that are similar
to The Prompt so imagine you have like a
um a document in this document it's
defined like the CEO of company X is y
and if you ask then the question
something like who is the CEO if you
have a good Vector embedding of your
text then this question and the chunk of
the document should have like a lot of
similarity and what the vector database
then does is like gives you a lot of
these chunks that are Sim similar to The
Prompt and instead of sending all the
documents to the uh llm together with
your um with your prompt you just select
uh select a few from the vector database
send them and let the llm answer it so
we are not going to explode the context
window of the llm we just have like a
few uh maybe a few thousand tokens and
this also makes it a lot easier for the
llm to uh reason about the uh data you
have given
it so that much for a quick introduction
of um of rag and now um we come to ragna
this is the uh project that quanite has
um open sourced like beginning of
November so roughly a month ago and I'm
going to show you how you can do rag
with ragna and um maybe even how you can
extend it and ultimately if time allows
even how we can build our own custom um
yeah custom mini uh web app to do this
okay so ragna is basically three parts
we have a python API we have a rest API
we have a graphical web UI and I'm going
to show you all of
them um so it's a little dangerous but
we're going to do this live I hope
everything works if it doesn't work I
have like a pre-run version of this
notebook um with me but let's see um
that we get it working okay so we start
off importing ragar we on version 1.0.2
just released fresh this morning with
all the latest Buck fixes so everything
hopefully works for this uh for this
talk um so the first thing that you got
to do in this whole process is you got
to have documents and I have a few here
locally um the interesting ones so the
first two these are just public
financial documents about Ford and GM
and the second one is actually one that
um Prov the third one is actually one
that provides some information about
ragna it's not really that important
what's in here it's basically giving you
a quick rundown of what ragna is um so
this is this are the documents that we
want to ask questions about and so
basically the main Imports that you have
from ragna all the time are um the rag
object which is um our main interaction
object we have the source storages and
the assistance so just to scroll up BAS
basically in this diagram this one here
is flexible in ragar this one here is
flexible in ragar and you can do um what
you like you can put individual
components in there we have a few built
in so just um to give you an overview
what we have built in we have for soft
storages we have chroma and lens DB
currently for the assistant we have
anthropic Mosaic ML and open
AI so if you want to use any of these um
assistance you got to have like an API
key so what ragna is not it's not an
extra llm it's not something that um
that can give you this this ex uh can
give you the LM functionality it
basically just wraps external apis or
even local local llms if you have one
we're going to see this in a uh in a
second and so what I'm doing right here
is I'm loading this API key from my uh
environment file um this is something
that you got to do yourself you got to
get like an open open AI open AI API key
or mosaic or anthropic although we are
very much aware that it's hard to get
these Keys except for open AI unless you
actually work with them um since we are
consulting company in this in this this
space we have access to them but um yeah
it's not uh that easy to
combine okay so if we have these key set
now and we are now able to use um GPT 3
.5 or gp4 this is basically the uh
interface that you're going to use most
of the time you have a rag object which
is basically defining this orchestration
and from in from this rag object you
have the actual chat and so for this
chat we provide documents that we want
to use we provide the source storage
that we want to use in our example
chroma we provide the assistant that we
want to use in our example GPT
3.5 um this is really fast it's not
really doing anything it's basically
just setting up the minimal uh these
minimal components so and then we have
um the prepare method the prepare method
is basically doing all the
tokenization um embedding of the
documents into your vector database and
so if we start to run this this um can
take a little while but it's not uh for
the documents that we have provided it's
not terribly
bad um since this is or while this is
running I can just um go go uh go
further in in this and uh just already
talk about the next cells if we have it
prepared this is a step that we only
need to do once from then on we can just
um we can just answer uh get answers
from our uh from our rack uh application
by just calling the um answer method on
this chat object and you see it here and
you see it here as well ragna is
inherently a think which makes it
possible to um yeah run this like the
the llms especially the external apis
they are inherently async because you
ask a question and then you wait for a
given amount of time to get an answer
and at that time you don't want to um
lock up your main threat so ragna is
built with full uh acing
support okay so um we saw that cat GPT
was not able to answer the question what
is the ragna framework um and now ragar
basically is able to answer this
question using GPT in the background by
basically providing it the source so you
saw like we had a document that provided
an answer to this question and now um we
get an answer if we ask it like hey what
is ragna and the cool thing here is we
uh saw it a little bit here the object
that we get back it's not just a string
but it's a message object object on this
message has um more than just um the
actual content it also has the sources
build in so in this case we can actually
look hey what kind of sources um did
this llm use in our case it used ragna
and it used some sort sort of the for
document that was probably the closest
although um yeah it's it's irrelevant
here um so why is why is these sources
uh these sources so important because
even though you're using this R workflow
you still have um the potential for
hallucinations like there's no guarantee
that the llm is actually going to answer
your question and thus it's uh really
important that you can check if the
answer is actual fact effect-based so
imagine I wouldn't uh like I would ask a
question about Ford here and I would
only get back sources that talk about GM
then I would know um that something is
up and that the answer cannot be
right okay that's that's it for the
quick rundown of the Python API but like
I said um ragna H also has like a um web
UI and the rest API and we have a little
treat for you we actually deployed a
version of ragna um for you that you can
try
out um you can click on the right side
in your in airme on the resources Tab
and you should see a link to um to our
web UI it's rag. kite. def you will will
meet by a login screen you can put like
this is like absolute demo
authentication like you can put any
username in here and the password is TR
ragna just make sure um this is um like
you all documents that you upload they
are going to our systems we're going to
kill this deployment um later this later
today but still please do not upload any
sensitive information here yeah and so
we're going to uh go to this right now
and see how it looks
okay I'm already logged in this is like
I have a few chats open here but um the
way you uh this works into in our webui
is we are clicking new
chat
oh I'm guess we're overwhelming the
system right now lot of people are
clicking okay so now it works um yeah so
we have the ab uh the ability to select
a few um assistants here let's go with
uh GPT 3.5 again and we have like a
source Sage here let's go again with
chroma we can upload
files now I'm going to upload the same
files that we had you have seen in our
um in our notebook
before if I click that we're going to
have the edding step in that time we
have to
wait
great Al righty perfect let's see um
exactly what you want to see in a in a
live
demo let's try one more time and if it
doesn't
work I'm going to blame it on the number
of people that clicked on that because
10 minutes before the presentation this
works
worked oh okay I got it now um so we can
ask questions something like what is
ragna and then we should get like a
small indicator hey I'm working actually
and
then
we should be able to see an answer to
this yes so we have like an answer to it
now the sources that I showed you before
they are available here as the source
info by Def the UI pulls a little bit
more context than the uh python API but
of course this is configurable so you
see we pulled a lot more sources here
but like the first two are exactly the
same than we had offline as well
okay coming back and I see we're already
quite advanced in a time um I'm going to
do now let's call this speedrun of how
to extend ragna um you can actually U
Ragnar's build in a way you saw it in
the in the python API you can put
whatever um whatever assistant that you
want or whatever uh Source storage that
you want in there and it should still
work so what we've did here is we have
um a small model that I found on the
hugging phase um Hub um taking about
roughly like four gigabytes of um um GPU
memory so it's basically the smallest
one available and um I've just
implemented it in this assistant class
um as yeah like subclassing the
assistant so we can use this in ragna
and ignoring all of the setup um up here
which is basically making sure that we
have all the requirements and making
sure we have the model the interesting
part is this answer method there is this
answer method really simple you just get
like the prompt you get a bunch of
sources you define a few additional
parameters that you like for example in
this case we are saying like by default
we are only going to um pull 256 new
tokens from um from our llm and then we
just basically have a prompt template we
put our sources in our prompt in we
tokenize this we put all of this onto
our GPU so with the do Cuda call we
generate some output IDs we DET tokenize
it and then we just return the output so
this is all there is what this uh model
is doing and with that we
can um directly put this into our chat
and run it now so if we see look at our
uh resources
here uh who you see my um memory is
already up um it's not it hasn't started
like actually working something it's
already loading the stuff but um the
utilization is still low okay so in
interest of time I'm going to skip over
to the next section so we can um see how
this is actually like how how this works
in terms of the um the rest API and the
guy because if you have defined this
class you now already have everything
set up so you can use it inside your API
or into your UI and for that I'm going
to skip over to a terminal and do this
really quick what we're not going to do
is this uh ragna in it um but we're
going to do this one here this basically
con gives you a configuration file uh
this one here I've already created it
for us um we can use it as uh as is so
what we got to do is is we have
the wa maybe we
just cut the file again you see the only
thing that you need to configure is this
one is coming directly from ragna this
one oh the color is really bad here I'm
sorry um this one here is actually the
one that we have to find so if you want
to start that we need to make sure that
our um this file this local LM is
actually on the pass it's in the same
directory so we're going to use that um
and then we have we can just
do M run so we load the um open AI key
we don't need even need it for um for
our local LM but I still have it in the
configuration and the only thing that
you need to do is ragna
DOI I'm going to load it uh very soon
and maybe if we have time after the
questions are finished um then we can
look at how this how this looks like in
webui but right now we're already uh
pushing time so you see this is still
running we still have the full GPU
utilization we still have the memory uh
the memory is still completely full um
yeah my my GPU that I have locally is
not the uh newest GPU so um oh yeah
great it finished just in time so we got
an answer so this is like an llm that
was running completely local you never
we never hit any kind of um any kind of
output to an external API and we still
got an answer from it of course like
mileage will vary depending on what
model you're going to use but ragna
provides this um just for you so as a
Last Action I'm going to kill this colel
now so we
can get our memory back okay there it is
and I'm going to start this one
and I would say let's head over to the
questions and if we have time at the end
I'm going to show you how this
fares um inside our
UI conr are you up or should I moderate
this no
sorry
um if there are so I think there's a
couple questions yeah um um
here I put a question onto the stage
yeah that's was one um so ragna the idea
for ragna came up when we were working
for a client and we were doing our
initial um investigation of what what we
could use and we felt that you had like
two sides of the spectrum like you have
on on the like on one side you had have
the let's call it the the
experimentation Frameworks like let's be
it llama index speed L chain that
basically have connectors and for every
single resource that you can imagine but
given that they have so many um
components that they need to support
it's also really hard for them to um
have like a 100% user experience meaning
if you need to support a thousand use
cases it's really hard to make it
perfect for um a single one and we also
had some troubles I I honestly have not
checked in the last few months but uh we
had some troubles in the beginning with
like hardcoded values that were really
hard to set from an up high perspective
and that really frustrated Us in the
beginning but no shade we still use
these these libraries to get uh to get
our feets wet and um that helped
tremendously
and on the other side you have like um
these fully Integrated Solutions be it
like Claw from En thropic that you can
use from their web UI you have jgpt
where you basically have no um ability
to change stuff you just it's basically
um you either take what they give you or
you leave it and um that can be
problematic if you have specific needs
or if you for example you don't want to
don't want to or can't send your data to
open AI for reasons then um yeah you're
basically you're basically left with
nothing and so we identified this hole
in the Middle where it's like okay um we
want to have a good user experience but
still we want to be able to configure
stuff and this is where ragna came
in time for one more question yeah um
how documents
embedded um it is right now U what you
see on screen it's hardcoded to be embed
on um number of tokens so you can vary
the number of tokens and you can vary
how much these uh chunks are overlap but
we already have like a feature request
and a repository and we're working on
making this more configurable for the
next release so right now we are
chunking on actual tokens um but like it
wouldn't be hard to to support like if
we have this generic um ability to to
configure this document level chunking
or paragraph chunking or whatever you
want to have um is certainly uh able to
to um to be
add